previously companies heavily relied on
traditional Hardware Technologies and
the transition to Cloud servers was slow
however the covid-19 pandemic brought
about a significant increase in the
demand for cloud computing without cloud
services fulfilling customer demands
would have been challenging for company
cloud computing has completely changed
how businesses and people access and
store data applications and services it
allows companies to adjust their
Computing resources according to their
needs which helps them save money and
work more efficiently with cloud
computing businesses don't have to spend
much on expensive Hardware software and
maintenance costs lowering their overall
expenses the growth of the cloud
computing industry and its Market size
has witnessed a remarkable surge in 2020
an estimated 252 billion dollars was
spent on various public cloud services
however recent stats indicate that the
spending on public cloud services
escalated to 304 billion dollars this
tremendous demand for cloud computing
has resulted in some of the highest
paying jobs in the cloud industry
choosing cloud computing as your future
career is clearly the right thing but
how which cloud computing career is
right for you how much you will get paid
don't worry we'll answer all your
queries in today's video we'll take you
through the top 5 highest paying cloud
computing jobs in 2023 but before that
if you enjoy watching these videos and
find them interesting please subscribe
to our Channel because we bring the best
videos for you daily also hit the Bell
icon to get notified whenever we drop a
new video whether you are a fresher or
an ID expert with some experience you
can improve your skills in cloud
computing by getting the proper training
and certifications on that note we
present the Caltech cloud computing
bootcamp by simply learn this in-depth
cloud computing online bootcamp course
lets you master fundamental principles
and develop the skills needed to become
a cloud expert you can become a complete
Cloud architect in just six months
whether you are a fresher looking to
make a career in cloud computing or any
working professional looking for a
change in your career you can opt for
this cloud computing boot camp not just
that but there are many other attractive
features of this boot camp like 40 plus
Hands-On projects and integrated Labs
will help you understand the concepts
better Capstone project in four
different domains make sure that you
have mastered this technology a bootcamp
certificate from caltex ctma is worth
mentioning in your CV live virtual
classes led by industry experts and
Hands-On projects and integrated Labs
simply learns career service is here to
help you get noticed by the top hiring
companies several other features are
also there in this bootcamp in simple
terms Celtic cloud computing bootcamp
helps you become an expert in designing
planning and scaling cloud
implementations from cloud provider
selection application migration and
performance testing to database
management multi-cloud deployment and
storage Services we have covered every
skill in this program to help you become
a successful Cloud architect so are you
ready to work for companies like
Microsoft Google Oracle LinkedIn and
Accenture don't wait until it's too late
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below we are here to
guide support and Empower you with the
skills to keep you ahead in the race so
without any further delay let's get
started the field of Information
Technology is constantly changing and
one of the best opportunities for
success in it is a job in cloud
computing so let's go through the top
cloud computing jobs that are in demand
right now and worth considering the
first job we are going to talk about is
the job of a cloud network engineer
Cloud Network Engineers are
professionals responsible for managing
Cloud infrastructures whether on private
public or hybrid platforms the role
involves enabling organizations to
operate with the flexibility and
adaptability required to optimize their
productivity while specific job
responsibilities may vary depending on
the employer or the project typical
duties include designing planning and
implementing client specific Cloud
Solutions selecting the more suitable
cloud service providers ensuring the
cloud Network can effectively respond to
user requests expanding cloud services
to support the growth of organizations
resolving issues as they arise
collaborating with stakeholders or
business owners to determine growth
strategies monitoring the utilization of
the cloud Network implementing robber
security measures for cloud Networks
ensuring compliance with relevant laws
and regulations
in the United States the average annual
salary of a cloud network engineer is
approximately 98 000 per year although
these salary figures might change
according to the person's experience you
might go a little lower than this if you
are applying for an entry level position
but you will surely surpass this with
time the next job we are going to talk
about is the job of a cloud system
architect
cloud system Architects are responsible
for strategizing planning designing and
enhancing various Network and Cloud
projects within an organization
they collaborate closely with IIT team
serving as the primary resource for
troubleshooting Network architecture
issues and proposing system improvements
to excel in this position candidate
should possess substantial experience in
handling Network and Cloud Technologies
additionally they should demonstrate
exceptional technical problem solving
abilities and strong communication
skills
in the United States the average annual
salary for a cloud system architect is
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
per year
the next job we are going to talk about
is that of a cloud database engineer a
cloud database engineer is a
professional who designs implements and
manages databases hosted and operated
within cloud computing environments as
workloads are increasingly transitioning
to the cloud and the popularity of
database as a service grows database
administrators are now more involved in
working with cloud-based data these
professionals play a crucial role in
managing cloud-based databases and
guiding businesses in adapting new
technologies such as the internet of
things blockchain and AI which are
enabled by cloud computing
they collaborate directly with Business
Leaders managers and customers to
determine the most effective ways to
leverage data for solving business
challenges
in the United States the average annual
salary for cloud database engineer is
around 110 000 dollars per year the next
job is that of a cloud security analyst
Cloud security analysts play a vital
role in ensuring the security of an
organization's Cloud systems and
recommending specific measures to
strengthen overall security particularly
related to Cloud usage these
professionals are Hands-On in
identifying potential vulnerabilities
and addressing security requirements
during an organization's migration to
the cloud
candidates for this position should have
a strong background in computer science
and engineering and knowledge of the
latest security protocols authentication
and certification basic requirement for
these roles include excellent analytical
and communication skills and familiarity
with cloud services like AWS Microsoft
Azure and gcp is advantageous
in the United States Cloud security
analysts earn an average salary of
around 87 000 per year the last job we
are going to discuss today is that of a
cloud automation engineer Cloud
automation Engineers develop and create
automated solutions for cloud
infrastructure including scripts and
code for resource provisioning and
configuration they maintain and optimize
the performance of cloud-based
infrastructure by monitoring
troubleshooting and implementing
necessary changes by collaborating
closely with various ID teams such as
developers operations and security Cloud
automation Engineers ensure that cloud
infrastructures align with
organizational requirements and supports
its objectives
in the United States the average annual
salary for cloud database engineer is
one hundred and three thousand dollars
these salary figures might change
according to the person's experience you
might go a little lower than this if you
are applying for an entry level position
but you will surely surpass this salary
with time
so which of these cloud computing
careers you found the most interesting
let us know in the comment section below
and with that we have come to the end of
this top 5 cloud computing jobs in 2023
I hope you guys must have got an idea
about the different job roles in the
field of cloud computing if you still
have any question or doubts related to
that let us know in the comment section
below and a team of experts will help
you at their earliest thank you so much
for being here today we'll see you next
time until then stay safe and keep
learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign